drôle de partie de pêche pour alain et
toute son équipe
ce ne sont pas des poissons qui mord à
l'hameçon mais bien des épaves de
voitures une dizaine de carcasses ont
été recensés et balisés dans ce secteur
aux commandes de sa crue à là on est à
son 6e relevage depuis le début de la
journée mais les bateaux sondeurs de
l'ennemi enfin du jeu des élèves qui
sont passés de là ils signalent les
voitures après l'âge en armes et en zone
rurale dans une ville c'est la police
donc chacun est venu plonger voir s'il
n'y avait pas des corps
et puis de là ils ont balisé des
commandes et élague des bouées et suite
à cela nous on passe derrière puis on
sort on sort en sort au delà du risque
de pollution que représentent ces épaves
immergé il y ait un réel danger pour la
navigation fluviale
il ya effectivement l'aspect pollution
au milieu naturel donc là c'est le code
de l'environnement qui est qui est visé
il ya également les aspects donc
sécurité de la navigation
parce que certains de ces véhicules
peuvent être dans le chenal de
navigation donc peuvent gêner
potentiellement la navigation et puis
aussi les impacts potentiels sur les
ouvrages de navigation notamment sur les
barrages
cette campagne de nettoyage est menée en
étroite collaboration avec les forces de
l'ordre
deux agents de police relève ici les
plaques d'immatriculation pour savoir
s'il s'agit de véhicules volés pour les
véhicules volés donc l'articulation avec
les forces de l'ordre consiste à ce que
les forces de l'ordre mais en date en
fait un dépanneur pour évacuer le
véhicule avec toutes les procédures
juridiques bien sûr qu'ils sont liés
pour les véhicules qui sont non volés en
fait donc vnf
une fois que le véhicule dont est sorti
va extraire le véhicule le mettre sur un
site de stockage et ensuite donc il y
aura toutes les procédures
administratives qui consisteront à ce
que les assurances des propriétaires
prennent le relais pour l'évacuation des
véhicules
les propriétaires des véhicules non
volés pourraient être poursuivis pour
pollution et abandons d'épaves
au total 28 voitures devraient être
retirés de l'yonne entre villeneuve la
guyard et jouanny